I was born in the heat, and I lived for five
days. The first moment when it was fair, I felt myself.
[Music] In a
dream, the first thing I was playing football, and after that, the
coercion happened. When the first time was long, I found myself sleeping on the other side, and I found dust, stones, and a bird's nest, so my brother, Muayyad, may God have mercy on you. The bad thing came from here.
From
[Music] Here, take
care of the one who pulled me out and
brought me closer to the bombing. You kept me awake and near Al-Awda Hospital, but you kept me awake with the
girl. You kept me awake. They brought me
to Al-Aqsa Martyrs Hospital and he sat working in
operations. After that, I woke up. Praise be to
God. Also, more, more, more,
more. Before the bombing, I was playing.  I used to play in a
football club called Al-Wahda Academy.
[Music]
I am struggling with my injury, and this is the previous one.
I dreamed of my dream of playing football, but if I
want to complete my dream, I want someone to donate me a
prosthetic limb, and I will continue and continue my education.
[Music]
[Applause]
I started thinking about everything.  One day while I was in Al-
Aqsa Martyrs Hospital, I started to go out, play, run,
read
[music] and
learn